what's going on reject nation my hair is
frizzy
welcome to part two of our reaction to
zack snyder's justice league this whole
thing is being cut up into several parts
if you missed part one there's a card up
here
pin comment top of the description box
full length uncut watch along where you
can sync
up with us is over at our patreon page
four straight hours of awesomeness thank
you to eric over at nerd chronic for
editing these reaction highlights for us
keep a lookout for part three anywho on
a party
anything on that kid from the liquor
store possibly
flash i had a dollar for every possibly
yeah make you even more insufferable got
a problem alfred
you've been working as if there's no
tomorrow to build this
team of people you can't even fight
found one i found two
well it's been some time since luther's
warning no barbarians at the gate
many of these barbarians don't use a
gate
maybe they're already here
keep looking what else do you have
just wait two more hours alfred
see a whole can of worms open up soon oh
that's a whole bunch of people in the
game
that's crazy it's it's harvard you've
seen the other one too to be like
freaking batman i already knew but the
pair of demons at the very top
oh that's so different
i could actually see a proper silent
stone tell your family i said hello
really offended by the why'd you say
that name
see a special cameo i was just thinking
that but he just reminds me of robert
forrester
yeah those are eerie
yeah like big old bugs
hey doc is the no adams to the electron
laser
ryan choi ryan adam star labs is a
private contractor we work for the dod
we advise them on xenoscience alien
technology
for example the superman ship
oh damn he's here in quarantine
working on an id sketch
[Music]
batman don't say batman yes
was there like directions on that thing
some kind of inscription
i remember all this in the other cut
it's pretty much the same movie yeah
you know i don't feel like enough people
point out that gal gadot is a pretty
attractive woman you know
no one ever points that out huh no never
the first one's ever to say nobody
ever brings up her appearance
there he is
like more of these heroic uh i like more
of these like horror ominous tones
oh yeah it really is building to like an
insurmountable threat
it's just like percolating under the
surface
it's on him
love the ironic touch of this song yeah
[Music]
wow
oh interesting
[Music]
king who would be mad bull cow what do
you want falcon
a mother box our people god is not safe
the time has come
take up your mother's pride
giant crab
and then this would have been our intro
to atlantis right
i thought he was going to slap him
[Laughter]
take up your brothers i really like
volkow's look in this one
yeah his worm tongue looks i definitely
prefer it over
the other one uh-oh i call to thee
oh the great one 50 000 more worlds
that's a lot to deliver huh count it
it's all there
look at this real [ __ ] carrot
no letters no krotonians this world will
fall
like all the others it's so exciting to
see it all used in the context
oh yeah
seriously he's got actual motivation
he's so desperate
yeah he's in a place of desperation
notice how good of a job i'm doing
senpai you know i paid millions of
dollars for this building security
took me almost a minute to disable it a
new toy
prototype troop carrier i once knew a
man who would have loved to fly it
trevor there are things from another
universe
they serve a dark power they came here
once before long ago
oh here we go here we go
small gods the leader of the invaders
was a being called
darkseid a name cursed and feared
in every universe the old gods
men atlanteans amazons
before their betrayal and enslavement
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it's like maximus and gladiator
booyah that looks great
[Music]
wow
no
[Applause]
let's put aside our differences let's
work together
time to join up
there we go lanterns
they're a lot more orc like in this
[Music]
movie
fighting together to defend life on
earth
boom
god look at him go oh
jeez
oh don't don't know why don't you take
that ring
damn zeus looks badass
look at that glorious blood
oh dear look at him go whoa
dang oh
nice yeah you guys look at you see how
bad [ __ ] they
actually are
jeez dude you see his bones
oh
they did what no world had ever done
sent
the enemies back into the stars
the boxes were left behind on earth
they grew weak dogs without masters
and then america was born
from these ashes
did we touch it should i stab it first
or touch it
oh he's spent on revenge
it's the one that got away
all right everyone we're going to seal
this in the most
mystical ways men let's bury it
there's some dirt on top i think this
six foot hole is deep enough
it's cold out to the dark place to one
of dark side's conquerors to garth
morengi's dark place
we have to be ready you me the others
he said the age of heroes would never
come again it has to
the others where are they
i don't know diana but you're gonna have
to repeat that story over and over and
over again
you're gonna have to tell it at least
five more times
you did a great job i wish i'd rather
love it
that's the end of part two people if
part three is up there's a card above me
is in the pink comments in the top of
the description box
if it's not there you gotta be patient
i'm shooting these in advance
i don't know what the future is yet on
how these are being uploaded
but we're doing what we can so just keep
a look at or hop
on over